it's time to apply what you've learned
about markup techniques to the blog you
can use the same blog you were working
on in Lesson one or if you want you can
find a fresh copy in the downloadable
section at this point in the project
your images are looking pretty good but
there are a few opportunities to use
some markup techniques first off check
out this random smiley face it's a PNG
just go ahead and replace it with
Unicode there's really no reason for
this to be a PNG and of course what's a
blog without social media links use
social to add some social media links to
the bottom of the page I'll be adding
them to a footer tag but feel free to
add them however you'd like also notice
this weird flourish here it separates
the main content from the footer below
it it's a PNG which is obviously pretty
unnecessary so replace it with something
that does make sense in the solution
you'll see me just totally remove it and
replace it with some more subtle CSS
here's an option for you add a
responsive logo check the instructor
notes if you want some inspiration once
you have replaced this smiley face with
a Unicode smiley face and once you've
replaced the flourish with something
else using markup and once you've added
some social media icons a code will
appear on the page type that code in
here to continue